all right carlen
McMillan and Owen mure you guys are
husband and wife but you also
psychiatrists correct you specialize in
adult and
child psychiatry
psychiatry but more specifically um you
guys are involved in some more some very
interesting um what do you call them uh
things that
work said simply uh yeah so
Interventional brain medicine is what
I'm calling it these days uh these are
uh you know taking the knowledge we
learned in the training for Psychiatry
of like people feeling bad in what way
and using that to Target treatments to
the part of the brain that needs to
change for them um and so the kind of
first generation of that was
transcranial magnetic stimulation or TMS
which is a a you know taking Faraday's
law from the 1800s you know you
know the wire is the axon in the brain
changing magnetic field current induced
in a wire and you learn in one spot or
another or another how to not be so
depressed can you explain TMS for for
people that are not familiar with it
because to me it sounds like the most
exciting development for people that are
depressed or people it treats more than
just depression right it very much does
right um I I I did a video with a girl
named gwendelyn maybe six months ago
from San Francisco who came down and uh
she describes her depression is like
just debilitating like suicidal as a
teenager and she did TMS and she was the
cheeriest young lady you would ever meet
yeah it can be very transformative not
for everybody but when it works it's not
no but for how many people how many
people are taking ssris now yeah I mean
there's new data that it looks like
about two-thirds of folks that taking
traditional oral anti-depressants or
actually don't respond um so we're
really going beyond what there hugs and
drugs of no all the all the crazy side
effects from all those things yep all
the side effects um TMS doesn't have
that cuz it's so targeted and so we we
started in the in the 1980s figuring out
okay you can take this magnet and you
can create a response in the brand uh
Mark George at MUSC said well what
happens if we take this response in the
motor cortex and we move it to the front
of the brand and lo and behold it seemed
to do something so there was a pattern
of simulation they used and they did one
treatment a day for 45 minutes because
that's how long you could hold up the
paddle with your own arm and have to
duck it in a bucket of ice water to cool
it off and it was 5 days a week cuz
that's how often the research lab was
open and then we just did that for about
20 years same thing and we didn't change
it one session per day one session day
while takes relatively a long time
compared to what what we do and and it
worked well enough but it didn't it
wasn't great and it's not kind of a a
revelation to six weeks later have your
depression be over that can happen just
cuz that's what depression does um and
the real change I think is bringing
together both the knowledge of where to
Target in the brain um and that's been
work based on basic hundred years of
Neuroscience but fmri which is a movie
of the brain so golf swing right you
can't tell what's wrong with your golf
swing which is a motion Thing by
x-raying the club right that'll give you
some information but it's static and
it's a motion problem depression is a
motion problem in the brain and we can
see that in movie of the brain over time
with functional magnetic resonance
imaging no radiation but it tells us how
the brain is talking to itself we then
take a magnetic stimulator and
everything we learn is based on what we
call long term potentiation but a flash
card you see it and you look at it a day
later and you'll learn the thing if you
look at it enough days in a row but
it'll take a while you look at the flash
card every hour and you'll learn it
faster
TMS works the same way and so shocker
when we change that pattern and we
change the time between those
stimulations we were able to learn the
lesson which is get less depressed or
less obsessed or less traumatized faster
and putting those things together where
in the brain based on the movie and how
frequently and with what kind of
spacing we can get people to remission
of their depression or their Obsession
or their
suicidality more quickly than anything
we've ever done
in medicine uh in Psychiatry at least
these are rapid acting treatments in in
some cases there are people who remit in
a day there are some people who remit in
day two or three day two or three is
actually the
average um and this is just the
first thing that we've done this way
there's more coming yeah just to be
clear so it's instead of 36 treatments
over like 8 weeks we're talking 50
treatments in five days so 10 per day
it's really much more condensed I I you
use the flash card thing I like to say
you don't go to the gym and do one sit
up right you do you do your reps you do
your circuit that's what we're doing
with the accelerated TMS and you once
you've done the 5-day
treatment you're permanently fixed or is
it something you might have to go back
one day you might have to go back it
really depends and most of the
treatments in Psychiatry are are like
that right gwend and the girl I
mentioned earlier who did TMS she had
she has not been back and she's still
it's been years and she's she's fine
yeah it really depends so I think some
people are able to come off their
medications others stay on um some
people end up doing a lot of therapy and
that kind of reinforces the changes that
they're making in the brain they're able
to develop new habits new ways of of
thinking and they may not eat it again
other people have the type of mood
disorder where you know maybe it creeps
in in 6 months maybe it's 6 years um so
there is variability um so we always let
folks know that but to me it's more like
okay we have something that works and
that's great because these are people
where stuff wasn't working they were
just you know kind of trying one thing
after the other and now you have
something okay this is an active thing
we know it works you know if your
depression comes back we can do it again
yeah and and I found out about this when
I got this treatment myself you you you
had it yourself yeah mhm tell me about
that and and so for me it was the end of
my uh General Psychiatry residency it
was the spring I think it may have been
right after this last trip to L LA
actually I think you're right because
the time change was kind of rough going
back to the east coast yeah so I have
bipolar disorder and that predisposes
you to having mood episodes and
Springtime plus a time change from a
flight can be enough to knock you into
depression and that's what happened to
me and I had just gotten into my dream
Psychiatry program for child psychiatry
fellowship and I was about to get
married to you and I got horribly
depressed um and the really kind of
brutal thing about residency training is
you have to complete X number of days
and so I didn't have extra days I had a
fellowship starting on July 1st and I
had to get well fast and so I went and
saw my doctor and said okay what do I do
and he's like look I don't know what say
you've taken all the drugs um but we've
got ketamine in a study and we've got
this TMS thing which is kind of kooky
and I'm like I've review the data on
this it's garbage he's like yeah maybe
it's garbage but if it's not and it
works for you it's really easy to
recreate and I said no that's a good
argument I'll do it so you're forgetting
ECT yeah I did yeah I mean so I I you
didn't do ECT but I remember I was up in
Boston you were in New York I was at
mlan hospital uh working and and that's
really well-known psychiatric hospital
and I remember like calling the
admissions and being like could you know
my husband needs to come here um then
he'd get ECT which therapy forting act
well it we forgot it pretty quickly
because it wasn't going to work it was
not practical right you were finishing
residency you weren't at the point where
you needed to be in in a hospital and
but your Depression was debilitating I
mean it was work it was but not enough
that you needed to take that much time
and do the cognitive effects one of the
things with ECT is um you know you're
going to get some cognitive side effects
you're going to get some memory problems
and it can be a little under predictable
how is what um electroconvulsive therapy
so think of uh you know people have the
image of one FW Over the Cuckoo's Nest
um shock therapy it is still an
extremely effective treatment for
depression particularly psychotic
depression um and it still has its place
but there are a lot of situations where
it just does not fit into people's life
and what they're doing um and for
somebody that is a physician who really
needs their memory needs to be
functioning you know pretty quickly
after treatment it wasn't going to be a
good and that's and just to be clear
that's very different from from TMS TM
yes so T that's using electricity TMS is
using magnets how do magnets affect the
brain and so your brain is an it has
neurotransmitters if you're a Pharma
company but practically those are just
doing kind of The Last Mile problem
between neurons most of the
communication is electrical and so it's
actually patterns of uh rhythms that are
synchronizing or asynchronized in the
brain it's like a band each kind of area
of the brain is firing in a rhythm and
sinking
up with another section of the brain and
this is how the brain overcomes the
energetic problem of of trying to when
you see fish swimming in a school they
don't like exchange notes in advance
about like when to turn left right your
brain is doing the same thing internally
and actually between people so I look at
her and she nods not because I told her
to but because our brains have formed
models of each other inside themselves
with these patterns of firing and so
we're dancing to this Rhythm
together TMS changes that Rhythm
directly you don't have to hear music to
syn up it's just going directly into
those neurons and says no this is the
Rhythm this is the pacemaker this is the
metronome syn to this and then the rest
of the brain
does you can snap I can't snap and and
that changes and that lets us change
depression by it's a cheat code remember
Nintendo like start stop up down up down
left right um there's a code to get from
the surface which TMS can stimulate to
those deeper brain regions that are out
of sync right and the out of sync brain
region that we're using in depression
treatment is usually the subgenual
singulate it's a Target when we do
neurosurgery for intractable depression
we go right down into that spot in the
brain and there's a spot for everybody
right here somewhere that you can see on
that brain movie the ideal spot for you
that is connected to that deep brain
region and you turn this on and it turns
that deep structure down and that
relieves depression because the
pacemaker which was basically Out Of
Tune with your experience gets back in
sync with what positive would be right
and the say neurons that uh fire wire
together so you're basically reinforcing
these connections and telling the brain
hey it's time to sort of start learning
again it's time to be active and how
does how does Depression happen in
somebody in a young
person million dollar question how does
it not H how does it not happen in this
day and and that's actually I think the
more remarkable question we're all
getting through the day and most of us
aren't crippled by depression when
things can be really dark and so I think
that resilience as a midpoint
that we've evolved to live with that's
really the remarkable thing on a
day-to-day basis that we can go through
the world and be okay and I think
people will you know just like if you're
you know trying to walk on a bumpy path
and then it suddenly gets even right
your gate is going to
change and what I imagine happens is our
our kind of emotional gate gets out of
whack and now we're walking on a flat
Road as if it were a rocky Shore and
that doesn't work well because it's not
the right walk for the right context and
so I think of depression as an
adaptation to the wrong environment and
the same could be said for worry anxiety
and even trauma I think trauma is the
best example of that you have a huge
thing that could have killed you and now
you're ready to not die even though
that's not what's happening maybe ever
again in your life so the so the
application for TMS could be much wider
than just depression very much so I mean
like when you're when you're talking
about trauma that could affect addiction
and yes alcoholism yes yes we have
addiction targets there is actually an
FDA approved TMS protocol already for
smoking cessation uh we're using it in
opit use disorder off label at AAA
clinics um in in Sunnyville um and in
actually one of the early cases we
published in Brooklyn was on a cocainas
disorder right um and and this is
actually kind of a good example of there
there's no current established like
effective treatment for cocainia
disorder you're in the woods and a
person came to me who was a physician he
said I've been using cocaine I need to
stop and what you think when you're
getting this brain stimulation matters
it brings the neurons in your brain
closer to firing and that means the
brain stimulation becomes more effective
because we get more neurons per pulse
and so for him he had to be craving
cocaine before with the target we used
and then when he was getting the
stimulation telling himself the story of
why he wanted to quit and it got harder
and harder over the course of those 13
treatments to get him to Crave and so
our technician who at the time was also
psychologist took him to the place where
he used Coke which is a local club right
and watched people blowing Coke in the
bathroom of that club 10 minutes from
the office came back got that final
treatment and he never used again yeah
yeah I think it's also important to
think of TMS as like a class of
treatments rather than being for a
specific disorder like we have pills and
some pills are for anxiety some pills
are for psychosis some pills are for
ADHD with with TMS it's just a way of
stimulating the brain and depending on
where you simulate uh you can get
different results prot you could affect
ADHD yes so yeah I mean so there's
different protocol different studies I
Don't Ed is more in research right so
most most people if you're going to go
to an office gambling shopping whatever
yeah addiction so there's definitely an
addictive circuit there's a specific um
specific TMS helmet and specific
protocols
OCD um depression those are kind of the
big ones people use it for bipolar
disorder um areas that are more
experimental would be like ADHD um there
is even like a study for psychosis I I
have a patient who was in a study uh who
had really bad chronic um auditory
hallucinations for many years and had
tried many different
antipsychotics um and of course those
had a lot of side effects and then went
to the study and um the hallucinations
went away and you know quite a few
months later they're still they're still
gone and the dosing of medication that
that they're on is much much lower so
and and what's great about TMS also
there's no drugs that's right it doesn't
mean you like if you're on you know some
medications and they're working for you
and all that you can stay on them you
don't have to come off of them but a lot
of people find they don't need as much
or any uh a lot of this work comes from
um what's called the human connectone
project um which is run by a doctor
named Mike Fox and others my colleague
Sean siki has done a lot of work on that
and they took essentially a bunch of
people who had strokes and then saw what
happened with those strokes and
overlapped all those brain scans well
this part of the brain is gone this part
of the brain is gone this part of the
brain is gone and in all of those people
they have a problem with addiction now
or they have a problem with Mania or
they have a problem with depression and
so they were able to map by overlapping
one lesion over another oh if all these
damaged areas in the brain all lead to
the same region maybe that's the same
network
and so that let us go from Imaging data
of the brain to plausible targets and
then stimulating those targets with TMS
is one way of changing those circuits
and so what we're seeing is even when we
have a new case where they've never been
no one's ever been treated with brain
stimulation for this before we still
have this data from the human connectone
project which lets us come up with a
rank order list of things that might
help and because it works so quickly we
can actually adjust rapidly what we're
doing based on how that person responds
even in day one or two and so a
degenerative brain disorder like
Progressive superclear policy which is a
Parkinson's plus syndrome even the
balance changes and we can measure
that um Dr Nolan Williams just published
a study called the shift trial where
they were able to change
hypnotizability which is a cool and
unsettling deeply unsettling but it's
very cool uh your ability to hypnotized
yes MH which is a which is a trait like
some people are hypnotized easily and
others are not and maybe take pride in
that either way and with the study
showing that you can actually modify
that which I think is a good proof of
concept but also yeah it's unusual it's
so exciting yeah it's very very very
exciting very exciting a lot of people
don't know about it it's just not talked
about as as much as it should be this is
approved by the FDA so the it is
definitely approved for depression um
OCD and smoking sensation again specific
protocols anxious depression also
anxious depression and then um very
excitingly last year uh the saint TMS uh
protocols sort accelerated
neuromodulated uh e guided yeah I can't
Stanford acceler intellig neurom
modulation treatment St great brand name
um was FDA uh cleared every all devices
are cleared not approved but yes the FDA
said this is uh this is acceptable um so
those are all good to go and then some
of these other things that we mentioning
are off label or as part of research
studies so insurance won't necessarily
cover it so insurance covers I mean just
because something's FDA approved or
clear doesn't mean they'll cover it
either um it was approved for OCD in
2019 and we're still seeing um only a
few insurance companies paying for that
the daily depression one that for about
8 weeks most payers Medicaid Medicare
commercial
they are going to pay for that for
depression for people that have tried a
number of different anti-depressants but
when you start to get to this um you
know multiple per day five five days six
weeks that's a part that is not yet
covered um how how expensive would that
be yeah so it varies um but typically
you need to get the the scan first right
you need you need the cost of the scan
and then it's you know going to be
several hundred dollar per session and
if there's 10 sessions per day so you
know we are talking usually tens of
thousands of dollars um some cures
depression yeah I mean depends yeah yeah
it VAR various part of the country but a
lot of times the people that we're
seeing coming in for the five-day
treatment they might be people that
otherwise might be needing to take a
leave of absence from work which is
which is costly um or going to private
pay residential programs that are more
,000 a month to do nothing yeah and then
there's some actually employer employers
that you know are called self-funded
when they pay for their own insurance
sometimes those employers are actually
willing to pay for their employees
because they want that employee to be
working and so for them it's worth it to
pay for those five days to put it in
context I was I was having this
conversation with a medical director of
a major plan this morning at 6:00
a.m as you do you think that was unusual
morning it's not it's not um and and you
know in in in good faith I have to say
he was really looking to move the ball
forward but the average drug comes to
Market in 2023
for
$180,000 a year for one person that's
the average medication in 2023 some of
these fancy ones because if you're they
new no that's not some of the fancy ones
that's the average new medicine it's not
the $2 million Gene therapies that's
literally the average rug yeah but yeah
a lot of times if you think of a a newer
newer anti-depressant or something like
that it could be between one and $2,000
a month um Hydro the hydr bromide salt
of a plansin right so well Butrin is
hydrochloride salt of buproprion well
they put bromine in there instead so
it's a different salt and instead of 300
bucks a month it's
$2,499 a month right there is just no
limit on how insane drug prices can get
and psychiatric hospitalization very
expensive can be hundreds of thousands
of dollars an emergency room stage so a
lot of the costs of care are not just
the medications but the higher levels of
care um and so hopefully you know with
TMS people are able to minimize that um
and then either able to not be on some
of those medications um or Beyond less
of them if people when people get
strokes they know what to do right if
you get go to the hospital everyone rep
recognizes the signs of stroke uh a
heart attack you don't around with
a heart attack it's disabling and you'll
die the disability from severe
depression if you look at it just on are
you able to do stuff
is the same amount of disability as
having an acute heart attack right now
we don't treat it like an acute heart
attack and we don't treat it like an
acute heart attack you know if you're
having an acute heart attack you need
help you need it in a hospital we're
going to do a bunch of things and we're
not going to quibble about the cost
because we need you to not die and not
be disabled but even if you have like a
suicide attempt or something and you you
know you go into the hospital there's no
guarantee that the hospital is going to
be helpful um or be able to offer these
treatments right so in fact almost none
of them do like only one out of 10 acute
hospitals offer electroconvulsive
therapy which is that best treatment
we've had that we mentioned most of them
are giving you less options than you can
get in the outpatient setting not TMS
and not TMS because there wasn't a
payment model yeah this year uh thanks
in part to me being a pain in the neck
to a lot of people and writing a bunch
of articles about it the first step
towards changing that happened so the
center for Medicare and Medicaid
services agreed that acute care atry can
start getting paid extra for new
technologies like Saint under Medicare
and it's not everyone covered by
Medicare which isn't everybody but it's
a lot well that hospital if it has the
right contract which is 25% of hospitals
now can get paid more just like it was
an IU right the reason we have cool
things like left ventricular assist
devices and extracorporal membrane
oxygen all the Miracles of modern
medicine in an ICU setting that's all
there because they built a payment model
to support it and Psychiatry didn't that
until this year yeah this is a new world
for Psychiatry to be able to have these
types of devices and interventions that
are truly uh bringing us kind of to
parody with the rest of fields of
medicine I think right now going into a
psych Hospital you're not going to see
this but hopefully within the next
couple years uh maybe faster you guys
like that will be something that people
can have if so if they need to be in a
hospital setting they'll be able to get
it right now most of it is outpatient or
you know research and and just just to
explain for people who lost track yes
there's TMS which is transcranial
magnetic stimulation and then there's
Saint which is the 5day speeded up 5 day
treatment both both are not available in
in hospitals but can you imagine an
impatient stay uh if you're running an
impatient Hospital a 5-day treatment is
going to be well better than you know
8we long-term thing so the 8we thing is
never really going to be viable for the
way that lengths of stays are these days
so and who wants to be depressed longer
yeah it's it's not once you know you
can't unsee it once you know something
can work in five days doing it over that
eight weeks is painful sometimes you
have no choice because that's the only
way it can be paid for um and that's
really frustrating um but I think the
future is going to be this more rapid
acting method for sure no that's why I
wanted to do this video just to get this
word out so that more people would would
learn about this yes oh and when you
when you went
through the you went through the rapid
like 5day thing I didn't no that was
back in the day that was ear so In
fairness my doctor was enough was on the
edge of science enough to give me two in
a day was really but the the treatment
really it still helped you yeah it still
helped I mean I I was back at work seven
days later and and you were like a
little better A lot better A lot better
I mean I was I was there I remember that
he was really really depressed and um
just wasn't enjoying anything and
depression is such a terrible it was
awful and I mean he had so much to be
excited about to this is the thing is it
it's it's like Mis it's like a
thermostat doesn't know what temperature
it is right so it's like you're exciting
you're getting into an exciting training
program we're getting married we're
moving all this good good stuff and
didn't did not matter right and so um so
depressed and I remember we went to one
session it was the first time I had seen
him get this and afterwards we went out
to a restaurant and it was the first
time in many weeks that there was any
interest in food at all any kind of
enjoyment any kind of smile um and
that's the thing is oftentimes people
around the person getting the treatment
will notice like more facial expression
nor more light in the eyes these subtle
things that the person sometimes doesn't
even notice until further along but you
see it it's it's undeniable that you
know when someone's responding they just
look and just feel different to sit with
so and and for me that was a good
example of a a kind of like cookie
Doctor Who worked too much learning
something new as possible because my
doctor had 5 days a week in his
Manhattan office and he saw other
patients up in Mount Kisco which is
where this office was too far away but
um the treatment was developed in the
context of doing it five days a week and
almost everybody did that this guy was a
workaholic uh and so he had another
office that he went to on the weekend
weekends right yeah yeah and I got five
days of treatment in that first week and
Saturday of and I was like a robot power
ing
down and she hadn't seen any of it came
and saw me and I looked bad and she's
like why don't I drive you to MCO yeah
and actually I think he opened it's like
plugging the phone in and getting the
juice again and the phone comes to life
right I mean that's how that's and
that's the other thing about TMS that's
nice is that um people if they are able
to work and and go to school and things
like that they can do this and they
didn't just take a little time out of
their day to do that once a day one um
and a lot of places they open nights and
weekends because of that and then if
they're going to do the same one The
Accelerated one basically take a week
off which is like way more doable than
taking months off on disability or in
hospitals that seems to make such perect
sense because if you want to cure your
depression you want to cure your
depression yeah yeah you don't want to
like mess around and you don't I mean we
don't do that with with pneumonia oh
like let's do just like really no you
want to do these things we only have
doctors 5 days a week for
pneumonia right but that's literally
what happened like we
I think always had a sday a week
practice because we didn't want people
to not get Care on the weekends because
this is serious yeah I don't know if
it's good for my lifestyle but it's
certainly better for patients to be able
to get two of those days to be on the
weekend has your depression ever reared
its head again yeah and then I got TMS
again but you don't or four treat but
usually yeah he gets like a little
booster which is actually quite common
is that people don't need that full
course again they just get a little
tuneup let's explain what TMS is like
when you're actually getting the
treatment yeah so um it it's one of the
things that's like uh you know when
morphia says no one can tell you what
the Matrix is um and so I can explain it
describe it and it sounds stupid um the
way my technicians like to describe it
is it's like a humming an angry
hummingbird banging on your baseball
helmet with a ballpen hammer um and or
woodpecker heard woodpecker well
woodpecker is if it's using the older
protocols at 120% it's a lot harder um
but you're having the the sensation of
getting some tapping on your head very
rapidly painful or no in the beginning
the experience is often described as
painful uh and then it's not anymore CU
you're it's just the the pain signal
just abates goes away um but there's no
scarring nothing no no no scarring your
your muscles and your face like twitch a
little bit um but like while you're
getting it and I I have not had a full
course or anything I have tried you know
just to to feel it I think I got it like
for three days and I can remember the
first day was like pretty painful um
this is just one little session right so
just a few minutes and then by even by
the second day it was fine and by the
third day I was just like on my phone
looking you know it was fine and there
are people who who get it you know even
intermittently at you know really high
power her just like whatever yeah you
don't see people really very rarely do
you see people saying oh this is too too
painful I I can't continue sometimes
people are like oh I have a headache
today I need to stop early but they come
back the next day it's definitely a
different experience than when you
prescribe drugs and you have drugs you
know probably would work at the higher
dose and you know people stick with them
but they can't stick with them because
they have unacceptable side effects you
know they can't tolerate of these
multiple treatments each day how how
many a day so the the same protocol is
is 10 10 a day um how long is each
treatment eight and a half minutes eight
minutes yeah and then you wait like 50
minutes in between so you hang out at
the office 5 Z yeah 5 Z and that's
clutch that's spacing between treatments
which by the way is the same optimal
spacing for flashcard learning yeah um
space learning the space learning theory
is the is the neural basis of it the
brain seems to like that it seems to
learn that way yeah yeah and that
pattern of stimulation space pattern of
stimulation each next treatment is more
potent than the treatment before because
the treatment before set the brain up to
be ready to learn the next thing and
that's why 10 in a day is actually the
equivalent of 36 over 6 weeks and so
when we do 5 days of 10 in a day it's
the equivalent of seven months of once
daily TMS yeah so it's not just the same
as if you did 50 daily it's it really is
quite uh we think there's something to
that Beyond just the fact that it's way
more convenient yeah how how many people
have tried this a lot well over a
thousand for Accelerated yeah for um you
know standard TMS I don't it's been
around since 2009 so lot I've personally
delivered 100,000 TMS treatments not
100,000 people but sessions s yeah uh
published um accelerated cases were on
the order
of I I have 202 10 a day personally um
my colleagues at AAA have
published probably about 300 now and
there are about 300 more we haven't
published um and there
are of those I think they're about 200
that are not n navigated and other um
two 300 all to 500 unpublished that are
have there been negative you know people
things that have happened so um there
the uh in in research we refer to these
as either severe Adverse Events or
treatment emergent Adverse Events which
aren't as bad um the worst thing the
worst side effects are seizure right
which happens very rarely and has never
happened with accelerated treatment that
we know of that's been reported never
been published yeah um and we I mean
among Sanford ACAA and verato but if a
seizure started to happen you would just
turn off the machine yeah yeah you just
turn off the machine so I've seen five
seizures happen in my career those were
all once a day cases um but nothing
right I mean we induce seizure with ECT
as a treatment right yeah and so I mean
people that have like a a an ongoing
seizure disorder it's this is not going
to be a good fit the mo most most of the
time we' use inhibitory treatment well
yeah there is a there is a special
protocol neurologists can use to treat
seizures but when we're talking about an
undesirable treat seizure um you know
oftentimes these are people who uh maybe
are drinking quite a bit of alcohol or
using
bipin and um maybe in mild withdrawal
like maybe they didn't drink or have the
med they take the night before so their
brain is a little bit more uh able to be
provoked in that way um and I you know
we haven't very rare that we would have
these seizures but I remember one person
was very far along in their course and
had a seizure and it stopped and was
fine and nothing happened and they
wanted to come back they they still were
like no this is working that's that's
worth it and you know as long as someone
knows the risks and benefits and you're
prepared to handle that I think I
switched to inhibitory treatment yeah
you can make some adjustments so there's
definitely things you can do um but I
think it's also important to note that a
lot of medications have seizure risks so
the medication Wellbutrin um
anti-depressant tons of people are on it
100 times RIS um significant risk of
seizure so it's not like and while
you're walking down the street not while
you're in a doctor's office this only
happens during a treatment during a
treatment during a treatment right an 8
minute treatment yeah the other risks
are uh headache fatigue jaw pain jaw
pain um I think the biggest risk is for
people who are hopeless if it's doesn't
work for you then yes if you think
there's nothing else that's a risky time
for for attempting or or completing
suicide or think about it and I worry
about that and so having other options
as next are there other treatments that
you guys work with like like what kind
of stuff uh so esketamine is an FDA
approved treatment that's an inasal
version of ketamine there know as pado
spado Jansen makes that product and that
has a mdsi indication major depressive
disorder with suicidal
ideation that uh looks like uh it works
about half of people but it doesn't
matter whether TMS worked or not for
whether it's going to work so as a
nextline treatment it's great because
it's likely to work and it didn't matter
if TMS worked or not it doesn't predict
non-response um some people aren't great
candidates for um you know a ketamine
type of product um intravenous ketamine
or semic ketamine the mixture of left
and right-and ketamine exists um the um
there other TMS targets right and so
sometimes you start here and then you
try here in the middle um we're working
on a transcranial focused ultrasound as
Next Generation brain stimulation
treatment um and that has tremendous
promise and psychedelic medicines exist
and are going through trials right now
there's reason to be hopeful right so
you have things like comp 360 which is a
psilocybin thing coming down the pike um
DMT 5mo DMT uh you know LSD for anxiety
has a 088 effect size which is like
making you three inches taller if it was
a hype medicine um Dr Williams also of
St Fame just published on I gain in
veterans with uh brain injury depression
anxiety and Trauma and 100% of the
patients in that study with no blinding
uh had remission of their depression
with one dose of ibigan treatment and
then you also do have ECT um iban is not
legal here no these are all clinical
trials and all that but yeah sometimes
people um you know might go on to get
ECT I also would say like there are some
people that have had TMS maybe 5 10
years ago maybe they had an older
protocol and so sometimes hear people
just be like oh teamus does not work for
me and then you find out what they had
and it's like the field has evolved so
we usually encourage those folks to give
it another go with these more modern
protocols um so and then I think the
other thing is like more is better and
so sometimes you have somebody who is
just it's going to take them more to
respond um and so maybe they've had 50
treatments and there's not as much
responses you would want but you keep
going and then they do get to that
response it's pretty rare to have zero
zero response sometimes if there is zero
response you know you do wonder is there
like personality style things is there
going to be like really intensive
Psychotherapy that's needed or other
types of external things that need to
change about the person's life um but if
you're talking about like depression
it's you know we're really able to be
creative and figure out how to get
somebody well in most cases and and just
just a couple times last week um the
gamma cor device which is an external
veag vagal nerve stimulator right it's
just sine wave to your nerve in your
body that controls
relaxing um I had somebody who got a
week of accelerated treatment to he
didn't do enough a week to hear didn't
do anything got a little bit worse gave
her the nerve stimulator just to hope it
would help with her anxiety and her
depression completely remitted in 3
weeks yeah and I'm just like yeah what
really and I'd heard of this happening
but I I wasn't expecting it because my
hope like my being hopeful hopeless
isn't a great indicator of whether it's
going to work right the data says it
might work so you should try it uh and
it did and so I didn't say yeah you're a
hopeless case I said let's try this next
thing and I I think that uh holding on
to the Hope from the data is what helps
get me through the day because the
hopelessness that I feel that's that's a
resonance from the person and they
suffering and so we get to feel what our
patients are feeling in a way that gives
us information but shouldn't guide us to
be hopeless right that's not the right
answer it's pretty rare to feel hopeless
about the folks that are coming to us I
think and some of it's just diagnostic
complexity figuring out just a broader
understanding of the person and then you
can figure out what's going to work for
them so it's pretty rare that it'd be
like wow you yep all hope is lost right
nothing to do for you you should just
give up now it's pretty rare to be
honest and that would be you know
probably that would be diagnoses that
are well outside what we're normally
taking care of and honestly you know a
lot of the time what we end up seeing is
the depressional lift and there's
another problem so I've sent 45 actually
47 patients now in the past three years
to Rheumatology because it turns out
they had an underlying autoimmune
condition and the treatment the
depression goes away yeah and then
something else kind of takes Center
Stage what typically will you see well
you still have I the depression's gone
definitely yeah but the brain fog only
for 2 hours in the morning weird fatigue
is still there so it wasn't depression
doing that and your joints hurt and
didn't you tell me you also had the
whole episode of diarrhea last year and
wait three years ago you had colitis and
let me check your
joints yeah they just were not focused
on it before right and so then they were
too depressed to this has been from what
treatment of depression with TMS with
TMS or yeah yeah it cures the TM it
cures the depression but then there'll
be something something else is remaining
right and then that may be something
that you need a medical specialist for
like a rheumatologist it may be
something that needs to be worked out in
therapy right but you're going to start
and then I think there is a risk to it
working there's a risk to feeling well a
lot of people's identities are very
wrapped up in this uh sick role and
their depression feels part of them um
and then to not have that it can be
frightening it can be sort of
existentially scary um it's a huge head
so I think I see that as as a risk
right and then people start to have
expectations for for the individual and
so we shouldn't underestimate that
that's going to be like you might feel
really different than you you know who
you think who you thought you are is
like not that that was that was a state
and not a trait that can be really uh
quite a lot for people you're going to
have different problems yeah like we're
not going to solve your problems it's
going to be different one of the really
one of the things we've seen not
commonly but we've seen a couple times
is we've seen marriages
end uh because people have been together
for maybe 20 years one partner is
depressed and the other isn't and in a
caretaker role and when those Dynamics
shift rapidly and nobody was expecting
them it changes roles in the family and
sometimes people realize that the couple
that was great when one person needed
constant caretaking doesn't fit anymore
yeah and they have they or jobs people
leave Jobs dead jobs but that's so
interesting that people get divorced
after getting better yeah yeah I mean
people would just make a change it's
like a catalyst for making some kind of
change in your life um and so that has
risks and benefits and that's just you
know kind of pushing someone towards
that next step it's a little the it's a
little opposite from psychedelic
treatments because with the Psychedelic
treatment you kind of get the the
slideshow or the the fireworks like
there's a big thing that's happened wow
and now you can kind of use that as a
pivot point in your narrative for your
life for Accelerated TMS it's boring
yeah people aren't saying you know that
they had this spiritual experience
during it but it makes them want to find
that in life like seek that out whereas
before they felt that was there was no
point to it so we had one of our early
uh OCD cases he said again nothing
really changed but I quit my job and I
got a new I got a new partner and I
don't feel like killing myself anymore
and now I'm doing this other thing I
guess know I guess lot of things like
everything changed yeah and therapists
really like it so we were with a lot of
therapists and they love TMS they don't
feel threatened by it at all because it
makes the therapy go better it makes
them more interesting they have more
stuff we we used to run a lot of groups
and I remember one one person was
getting TMS and I don't think they'd
shared that with the group and they
really weren't a very participatory
group member before and they started to
participate and people were just like
what's going on with you you're like you
know the star group member now and it
was TMS that had just let LED them to be
like I can now participate it's such an
exciting thing yeah it really is there's
there's a there's going to be a boom if
we get TMS out there in post TMS what
the f to do with my life now group right
which is not a trivial problem yeah yeah
it's a real thing it's weird to explain
to people I mean it's just you know it
looks a little weird then the world
becomes like totally open to you you
could do anything yeah which is that's a
lot of things you're your giant
roadblock has now been removed yes yeah
that's how it that's how it feels so a
lot of people with depression and
recurrent mood disorders build a life
based on fear and they're making
conservative choices about who to love
what to do based on what if the
depression comes back what if I get so
disabled again I can't and so they'll
make choices based on well if I'm
limping I can probably still get through
this program or this job and so I'm
going to do that and when the narrative
that you'll always be at the whims of
this recurrent character stalking you
you goes away then the narrative about
what's possible for you inevitably is
able to change and that is a huge
deal
and I mean I can't think of a better
reason to be a psychiatrist than to see
someone be able to have different hopes
than they came in the door with that are
better for them yeah yeah we we had a
brief period of time where we didn't
have a TMS machine coule years ago
um we transition businesses and we just
were like well we'll just do you know
Zoom visits and we'll do the med
management and it was intoler like I
needed to have it in order to feel it
would be like a you know Carpenter
without a hammer or something I just
needed that tool in order to um and
that's part of why like I have licenses
in multiple States but I don't um I
don't necessarily want to be taking all
these cases in other states because if I
can't offer them TMS then I feel really
hindered in my ability to help them in
the full extent um so once once you have
that tool you really want to be using it
yeah can can I change the topic a little
bit ask you guys what made you want to
become
psychiatrist yeah uh Kirk
Cain in the 90s yeah I mean when I was
in Middle School uh my favorite band was
Nirvana it was the first band I really
liked and then Kirk oing uh died by
Suicide when I was in seventh grade and
I just did not understand how that could
happen and it was very upsetting and it
sort of kicked off for me an interest in
Psychiatry psychology suicide wanting to
be helpful so that things like that
didn't happen um and then that was my
path like I I just knew from that point
on all through college all think I was
very directed towards doing that and
that's what I do now um so it was just
like a guided missile towards that yeah
I was also obsessed with Nirvana and so
I first went to work in a recording
studio
uh I worked at Sony Music Studios after
college I called up Steve Albini who
recorded in UD and said how do I get a
job in a studio and he said don't um I
should have listened to the advice um
and then my best friend from childhood
skied into a tree and briefly died his
heart stopped for just a minute the
first person who skied up was an EMT the
second person was an orthopedic surgeon
I had bipolar disorder myself I had been
depressed and I was terrified of going
to medical school and failing because
the depression would come back and so I
built my career path around never
risking that by never taking any Premed
classes and my best friend from age zero
had this horrible head injury and then
got horribly depressed and I went with
him every night every week for a year
and a half to a uh depression support
group um in the local hospital and it
was at one of
those visits with him that I just had
that Holy Light sound effect go off and
I'm like oh I'm going to be a
psychiatrist cuz I could probably do
that and people need
it um and here I am and being a a sound
engineer was not a great fit for bipolar
disorder up all night and all that kind
of stuff so this was a much better much
better fit soor that was Dr her off the
calback he has a patient getting
accelerated TMS right now in Chicago
yeah so um so for for me I had that the
Holy Light sound effect go off at that I
mean I wrote it down in my calendar it
was uh September 24th 2004 uh decision
day to go to medical school um and I
went to the University of Rochester
school of medicine and Dentistry which
turned out to be a remarkable place for
me um I remember making jokes at the
beginning of residency about um my uh
TMs in yoga lattes Clinic that I would
you know totally making fun of it that I
was going to open someday and I don't
know if it's that different from what I
like like movement plus brain
stimulation seems like seems like it's
the right the right uh the right track
yeah I have a patient who calls it the
happiness Ray and he thinks it should
really be um fullon something that
everyone can get we're we're not quite
there yet but you know it is pretty
powerful such such an interesting new
development yeah it really is um and
it's it look it's safe it causes no
permanent changes in brain
functioning
and the word cure is one we don't get to
use in Psychiatry very often if you look
up the definition
it says with no signs or symptoms of a
disease uh the FDA is a important
organization that has been misused by
Arthur Sackler and his family frankly um
to get labels on drugs that they
shouldn't have gotten and so the word
cure kind of got taken off the table for
a long time but if you go out and buy
mccol nitrate for your toe fungus it'll
say it cures toe fungus um fungus might
come back but but they still say the
fungus is cured they still say it's
cured no you don't say that in mental
health at least not until recently yeah
no signs or symptoms of disease well I
say remission uh recovery is probably a
better word like getting back to your
life having meaningful work or school
having a relationships outside the
family that's the definition of recovery
and that's what I hope people can shoot
for but unless we're
measuring and shooting for as a field
remission recovery and cure eventually
and we're not doing our job and 50% less
miserable isn't good enough that was the
measuring stick we used to measure
cognitive behavioral therapy to measure
SSRI
medications and a lack of ambition uh
poisoned our ability to understand what
a cure might even be for the greater
part of a century and that's changed and
that's awesome you know I don't use the
the word recovery very often because I
find that some people people they they
they don't have a time where they
weren't feeling miserable and they've
had traumatic childhoods and they just
haven't had a time where they're they're
happy so for some people yes they were
happy and then they were not but for a
lot of people recovery doesn't really
resonate because it's like actually
they're feeling a new way uh of being
yes they're feeling well which is not a
state that they had felt before in any
meaningful sense um so I would like kind
of Beyond recovery just sort of a new a
new level yeah but
my first week of Psychiatry training and
my first week of third year of residency
or medical school my attending said we
never get people better than their
Baseline he was a but it's not
true just he was wrong that's sad it's
that's sad if that's the way that it is
because that's not true yeah sometimes
you can yeah um and if we can find a way
to I mean our rating scales are a good
example all of the the phq9 which was
the patient Health questionnaire 9 a
screening measure later validated as a
rating scale which was a products I
think fiser made it to sell something um
that has as a time scale two weeks and
so even the question of how do you
measure depression that gets faster on
the time scale of days and not weeks is
not a trivial
question all of the rating skills assume
it can't be that fast and so some of the
work that I do is around artificial
intelligence and identification of
symptoms using Ai and so right now I'm
doing work with the NIMH funding to look
at a a side effect called tardive
discinesia which is a side effect from
anotic meds and we're using AI to see if
it can pick up that side effect earlier
earlier so people don't get disfigured
with
a movement disorder that nobody needs to
have forever as a side effect from a
drug they probably if with depression
didn't even need if they got to this
treatment first with
TMS and can we do the same thing to to
identify changes in depression faster I
think so I think so that's where my my
money's on it and my time and my money
my time I spend a lot of time working on
this problem because I think figuring
out how to measure it faster yeah and
biomarkers right so you know we have ASR
watches the Rings all this stuff
tracking but the they haven't sort of
formally made their way into the sort of
treatment rooms with psychiatrists and
other clinicians and I think we'll see
more of that where you'll be able to see
like you weren't moving around as much
you're sleep was a little off like all
the different things that we know happen
with depression rather than just
checking off boxes on a rating scale
we're going to be able to have that
feedback from these you know these
devices so that's that's exciting and
bringing together kind of the artificial
intelligence that's used so in in Saint
that accelerated TMS product um by a
Magnus Medicals the company bring that
to Market that uses an AI algorithm to
determine the target it's not a human
doing it
anymore and that gives us you know know
the spot based on that movie to Target I
think the other side of it matters too
which is okay but if you can do that
Target or another Target what's the
right target for Joe and I think that's
another AI algorithm that's going to
need to tell us okay based on behavior
and what we see of you and what you're
telling the world through words motion
you know really subtle stuff we can pick
up in voice
diabetes that's wild I still think
that's wild the study showing yeah and
voice picking up depression all these
different things so we have biomarkers
for Parkinson's based on how fast you
type you can pick up bipolar disorder in
uh Dr ol's research and so using all
those
different uh measurable things figuring
out what to Target for whom where when
and people don't have to wait they don't
have to wonder and that's the future I'm
looking forward to where we can identify
people who are suffering in what way and
fix it for them in a way that is
tolerable safe effective and fast so
they can get on to more interesting
problems in their life because there are
plenty of those
wow so interesting welcome to the Future
I'm glad you think so I'm glad you've
been yeah so interested in this yeah I
mean I just think all these
these uh anxiety and depression drugs
that everyone seems to be taking now are
just it's it's so frustrating for me
they're not good enough I mean they're
you know if they're working for you
great but they tend to be pretty
underwhelming and the folks that like by
the time you're seeing one of us
but the way the doctor is just like here
try this that didn't work try this yeah
it's they're dangerous drugs it's not
great I mean it's and it's like the
chances like okay there's people out
there they're going to get proac they're
going to get better but if that didn't
work the the such diminishing returns of
just trying one after the other as
though like the 10th one is going to
magically work yeah but like this girl
gwendaline that that I mentioned earlier
she was trying all these drugs and
getting nowhere yeah tried TMS works and
she was Che than all cheerer than all
three of us together yeah and seemed
like she's permanently that way yeah no
I mean you know some people we 27 Med
Tri it's not uncommon to see massive
medication trial history where they've
got nothing to show for it except
feeling miserable and these are the
types of people ending up in the trials
for TMS so it's not like the trials are
cherry-picking for like people with more
mild depression no they're picking the
people that the normal stuff wasn't
wasn't working and getting better so I
think we want to get to the point where
it's used even earlier than it is now
right cuz now you still if you're going
to do use your insurance you're still
going to have to have tried different
medications um but we really think that
it should be earlier in that line than
having to go through that multiple step
process I mean the standard now is that
you're forced to take a medicine that
makes more money for a kickback for your
health plan first that has a vastly
lower likelihood of working and even if
it does get your depression better or
even to remission well now you got to
keep taking it because the withdrawal
from those can be significant if it's
not tapered incredibly
slowly and so the thing you try first
matters because if it works it's a
heartbreaking choice to try something
else and risk depression again or
Obsession or worry or whatever it is and
if it doesn't work well then you just
wasted a lot of time it's very
demoralizing very yeah very demoralizing
to keep trying or because you might
think you're broken yeah
and it may just be that our decision-
making is what was yeah we don't say
that people fail like oh I failed this
treat no the treatment failed you the
pills failed you not the other way
around all right can I tell you my
favorite treatment emergent adverse
effect sure I had somebody I had to
check on this she said well my face
hurts because I was smiling so much this
weekend and everybody noticed it and
this is a person I'm following up on
after risk of fa Facial Pain
and she was a study patient and so I
deed well not anymore you're right no
but had been depressed yeah um and I
actually had to call the study sponsor
and say is Facial Pain from smiling too
much something I have to report to the
FDA that's a new one that's a new one as
a treatment I'm like I can risks may
include smiling so much it hurts right
and I've just never had SS an SNL SK it
does but it I mean it was a real the
answer was no by the way I didn't have
to report that great that's one
um but it may have been more meaningful
if I had right um we set up a system to
never capture the great things right
we're not capturing treatment emergent
remarkable
experiences uh and we're not set up to
do that and and maybe that's our own
failing of imagination that's a great
way to end it klen and uh Owen thank you
so much thank you super interesting I'm
so glad you guys came down and did this
yeah thanks thanks for having us this
was fun yeah we were up in the Bay Area
so it was easy to yeah pop on down yeah
I hope the world adopts it and it takes
off I hope so too thank you so much
thank you
bye